un avión con 132 personas a bordo se ha
estrellado hoy cuando cubría la ruta
entre con mí y guangzhou ha informado la
televisión pública china se desconocen
aún las causas del accidente no se ha
habido supervivientes aunque esa
posibilidad es muy remota porque un
funcionario que ha acudido a las tareas
de rescate ha revelado a la prensa local
que el avión ha quedado absolutamente
destrozado las imágenes tomadas por los
vecinos muestran las llamas de una
columna de humo emergiendo desde una
zona montañosa de la provincia de quang
y el último contacto con el avión se
produjo una hora después de empezar el
vuelo y poco antes de que el avión
descendiera 8000 metros en apenas tres
minutos el avión siniestrado es un
boeing-737 con seis años de antigüedad
que pertenece a china vista en una de
las tres aerolíneas más importantes del
país los accidentes aéreos son muy raros
en china que tiene unos registros de
seguridad más altos del mundo el último
accidente se produjo hace 12 años cuando
44 personas murieron al descender un
avión con poca visibilidad